we start this NewsHour in Ukraine where
President Vladimir zielinski's Chief of
Staff says a recent western price cap on
a barrel of Russian oil is not enough
and should be lowered even further on
Friday the G7 Australia and EU announced
a limit of 60 a barrel the Russian oil
imported by sea Ukraine wants that to be
brought down to 30 a barrel Russia says
it will continue to find buyers for its
oil and says it was a dangerous attempt
by Western governments the price cap is
expected to come into effect on Monday
that's the same day an embargo by the EU
will be applied on Russian crude all
right we have a team of correspondents
standing by but first let's go to Rory
challenge in Kiev Rory Ukraine says the
price cap doesn't go far enough what
more are you hearing
um
well look Ukraine has been calling since
the beginning of the Russian invasion
for a complete embargo on all Russia's
Energy Products whether that be oil or
gas whether that be Seaborn or pipe so
an oil cap a price cap on Russian
Seaborn oil you can see that from the
Ukrainian perspective it doesn't go far
enough Andre yermack who is uh President
zielinski's Chief of Staff essentially
has said that that price cap would have
to be thirty dollars a barrel half the
agreed price cap that's been announced
to be able to destroy or degrade
Russia's economy faster but he says that
it doesn't really matter because in a
you know bullish statement Ukraine is
defeating Russia on the battlefield and
ultimately whether the price cap is 60
30 or a complete embargo as Ukraine
would ultimately like
Ukraine according to the government is
still going to defeat the Russians and
still going to repel The Invasion Rory
Keith isn't the only one wanting a low
cap on oil what are other Western
Nations saying and what's needed from
them
well yeah I mean the the negotiations of
course within the G7 within the EU uh
have been fairly protracted they've been
talking about uh this sort of uh measure
for for quite a while and working out
how they're going to get to it now uh
Ukraine has a particularly strong
supporter uh in the EU in the shape of
Poland there's also the boulder
countries as well but Poland
particularly was essentially holding out
on this agreement because it thoughts
that it didn't go far enough either
Poland was arguing that there should be
a lower cap and there should also be a
mechanism in that deal to keep uh the
price of Russian Seabourn oil below the
market price at all times and it has I
think got that there is a mechanism
within the deal to basically maintain
the price paid for Russian Seaborn or
crude at least five percent below the
market price so that of course uh is is
cheering uh for the ukrainians and I
think the ukrainians know that
realistically a complete embargo on
Russian Energy Products was is not
likely what they will be uh enthused by
when they look at all this is that yes
this might not be as much as they wanted
but it still shows that they have
significant uh Western support it still
shows that even as this war is almost
certainly going to be dragging into its
second year and even though there is a
significant inflationary pressure that
the war has brought to bear on economies
around the world and even though the
cost of supplying Ukraine with
sophisticated Weaponry all of those are
high
the support seems to be unwavering at
the moment it's still there and that
will uh that will be a big chair to the
government in Kiev we really appreciate
the update as always Rory challenge live
for us in Keith